hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome
transition vas Kevin today I am
answering a question from one of my
fiber gigs fan is bonnie has a website
called power resumes com au and in this
gig I review somebody's website and put
it on youtube so we're going to check
out her site and give some advice so
it's on the site for a few minutes um I
i like this site so one of the biggest
challenges that I find when I go to a
lot of entrepreneurs websites are don't
really know what they do and how they
can help me so when you land on this
website you get to know really quickly
what it is that they do so they write
revis resumes right so it's pretty easy
to figure out what this business is all
about there's a strong call to action
here she's chatting to people to sign up
for her newsletter so it's great it's in
here it's also something at the bottom
where what's your next step and put your
name and email and there she's selling
her she's giving away this resume health
check consultation it's this great great
way to get lead generation going on so
from that perspective I really like it
so I know what you do there's a strong
call to action there's a video intro of
her on here which is great as well and
so great start ahead of ahead of where a
lot of entrepreneurs are when they
launched their website and she said this
is a pretty new site so congrats so far
on I'm having a good site things that I
would maybe change around or something
to play with first is the the logo it's
just okay I would try to invest in the
brand in a little bit and go to someone
like 99designs and have a logo made for
you it's probably gonna cost about 200
bucks but worth it and just makes the
the site look a little more professional
some of the pictures are very stock
photography ish so this picture here
this picture here looks like it comes
from a stock photo site which probably
did so fine but you use yourself in a
lot of the content as well here so this
is this is her picture here she's in the
video he's down here as well and so
you're very photogenic have a great
smile a very personal you can tell that
you know this is you and not some
stock picture and because you use
yourself so much and you you're trying
to showcase yourself as the expert you
know they get to deal with you and
you're going to help them get that dream
job then I would chill case that a
little bit more and put that more front
and center than having these guys where
you can tell it's stock photography I
would think about getting a well
actually I'm thinking about the US
market 1-800 number but this might be
toll-free out I'm hoping this is a
toll-free number if it isn't then you
should have a toll-free number and
there's a lot of options you can find
online to set up and it's not too
expensive it does add a lot of
credibility and authority I guess having
that one 800 number and making it
available I'm by default to think
wanting hundred being in North America
but you're in Australia so maybe that's
the Australian equivalent but hopefully
this is a toll-free number as you scroll
down here I didn't get the sense
immediately that this was pointing to
here and so there may be an easier way
to have an arrow that jumps off the
screen or something to show that this is
the health check that you get by putting
your name and information into here you
may also want to play around with the
call to action here so you're talking
about discovering the easy way to land
your dream job and from every test that
I've seen and run myself people will
generally do more to avoid something
negative than to go for something
positive and so people are struggling to
find a job I would try to tap into that
pain of again being rejected or you know
submitting your resume is constantly and
and not getting an interview at least
your first interview in that that's a
major pain point for people and I think
they're twig to that more than trying to
go land your dream job I know it can be
hard you know for myself I like to
spread a positive message instead of a
negative one but people are more likely
to take action if you can tap into a
major pain that they're facing and you
know getting the dream job may not be
their biggest pain at the moment is
probably
wondering why they keep submitting the
resumes and or not getting an interview
and so that might that might be worth
you know changing some of the word and
around at least playing around with it
doing some split test to see if that
will work better for you and then just
as I scroll down here it becomes a lot
of text so if you look at this it's a
lot of text for people to read I would
look at two things it's great that you
have these testimonials powerful words
and it's great that you know people
really like what you're doing I would
try to include pictures with these
people and it's great to have it on your
homepage a lot of others have it buried
somewhere deep so it's awesome on the
homepage I'd look for pictures of these
people so you know as a lot of times you
can just find it in LinkedIn or Google
searches find this person here and see
if they have any pictures so I don't
know if this is the person how common
this name is or not there's a linkedin
profile I might be able to go to images
and you know I don't know if this is the
person or not I don't know how common a
name this is it looks like it's no not
too common but you never know and so if
you can like she looks nice nice smile
she's doctor you know this is her then
that would be a great picture to put on
your website as well beyond just your
smiling face you know people will tweak
to that and they'll they'll be more
likely to read it and so it just makes
your testimony was a little bit more
powerful this I try to split up a little
bit more make it easier to read maybe
put little pictures next to each one or
put a little bit more spacing between
the titles the blue on blue can
sometimes be a little hard to read so
just you want people to read this is
some good quality information in here
and it's easy for your ID just to get
bored of this section of the page and
and keep going down so this is my
initial thoughts there you've got your
facebook and twitter feed here so let's
quickly check those out see what that's
all about so facebook facebook let's
close this stuff down facebook is going
to a different branded site so this is
interesting so your your business here
is called power resumes but
then your Facebook page is melbourn
resumes so I try to have a consistent
look for for both either call at
Melbourne resumes or call it power
resumes it's great you have your picture
here again nice warm friendly smile I
like this satisfaction guaranteed that's
kind of buried somewhere else here I
thought I saw something about a
guarantee you're guaranteed fast results
so it doesn't say I guess it's a hundred
percent guaranteed or what the what you
get back if you don't know if you're not
happy with it but this is a lot more
visible so you might want to put that on
your website as well and yeah I just
make the decision to Brandi the
Melbourne resumes or power resumes and
put your put your picture front and
center like you do here on your Facebook
page we loaded the Twitter account and
it goes to your homepage do you not have
a Twitter account Twitter ok so you
don't have a twitter account so I'd
either set up a Twitter account or
remove this because it's going to start
confusing people try to follow you or
find you on twitter and then let's take
one more look see what kind of resources
you have here and it looks like this is
a blog that you set up maybe wordpress
or something else we're looking at what
date is it now we're at April
seventeenth the last post is December
13th so that's been a while I would
consider either posting more frequently
or taking off the date if I look here it
says archive of articles you have three
articles in total and they're all from
december so if you look at this these
articles 12 competencies recruiters will
set you on that's something that's
pretty timeless so i don't know if
you're mention anything in here that is
specifically tied to you know 2012 or
news events but if if you're not
planning to write a lot this is all
you're going to do or you're going to
have one or two more then if somebody
comes to this page it looks like it's
outdated but the information you have is
timeless I would probably look at
removing the date off of these pages so
when somebody lands on it they just see
the reason
don't judge it as being dated because
they see that it's from sometime last
year anyway those are some quick tips
coming up on the just passed a
nine-minute mark in a video so hopefully
there's some good information in there
thank you for ordering the gig on fiber
I do like to say it again it's a
understand what you do if I had a
problem you know with my resume I you
know I get the sense you could help me
you do have a strong call to action you
have the video intro so that's all great
but hopefully you can also use some of
those tips that I just gave you to make
the website even better and keep us
posted with your progress I'd love to
see it again if you do redesign for
everybody watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up it
makes want to do more videos for you and
if you have a comment about this website
or a question for your own business feel
free to leave it in the comment section
below I always read those and love scene
coming so thank you and I'll see you on
the next episode